what do you make of this is it an
anomaly or do you think this is a
movement no I do think this is a
movement I think the next wave of
Democrats are going to be much closer
Bernie Sanders brand Democrats than even
Nancy Pelosi brands emma-crats and what
you see here is the the sort of howling
at the moon branch of the Democratic
Party in which they they throw out
whatever radical proposal they want and
then suggest that this is truly
authentic the moral clarity lies in
making proposals that are completely
untenable that will never be paid for
you know this this person was was on
MSNBC this morning and she was asked
specifically about how she pay for all
of this and she proceeded to blab for a
solid two minutes without giving an
answer to that question because she
doesn't have a way of paying for any of
this but of course the the Democratic
base has decided that it is much more
important to have somebody who is
virtuous signaling about why everybody
should have a government job and why
housing should be government provided
than to actually have candidates who
have policies that can never be
implemented yeah she was talking about
President Trump also earlier on MSNBC
and calling him a a Thorat Arian hyper
capitalist is the way that she termed
him and you know when you look back
let's look back at this sought from
President Trump and the difference in
President Obama is how they approach
capitalism if you've got a business that
you didn't build that somebody else made
that happen
nobody's cut regulations like we have
nobody's created tax cuts like we have I
mean there can't be sharper voices that
are more different on this issue than
we've had in the last two presidents Ben
no question but and I think that's what
the Democrats are picking on is the fact
that the Democrats have always been
moving in this direction at least they
have been significantly in the past
eight years there's a reason Bernie
Sanders came very close to knocking off
Hillary Clinton in primaries and it is
pathetic to say that a near octogenarian
is the wave of the future but I think
that Bernie Sanders has a lot more
acolytes among the under-thirty crowd
than Hillary Clinton ever did and this
is pretty good proof of that I thought
this was you know particularly ironic
lin-manuel Miranda who I think is is a
genius I thought Hamilton was wonderful
but I think it's interesting that
someone who essentially wrote a musical
that is a love letter to the founding
fathers and to the Federalist Papers and
to Alexander Hamilton is is applauding
he's saying congratulations to you you
know for this woman who is essentially
you know
not essentially she's put herself out
there as a socialist what do you make of
that yeah you know she's as radical as
can be but again it is very easy to
virtue signal about policies that have
no impact when they're never implemented
Bernie Sanders never did anything in the
Senate until he ran for president and I
highly doubt that any of the policies
that are espoused by Kashia Sanchez are
really going to result in anything real
here because it's it's easy to go home
and and say that big government is gonna
solve all your problems when it comes
time to hash out the actual legislation
it's gonna be pretty difficult to get
that stuff passed the Democrats who are
so all-fired eager about the new wave of
the Democratic future they may find that
this is not in the mainstream this is a
New York district it has been a
democratic district for 20 odd years I
mean longer than that but the the person
she replaced had been a tantrum Congress
person so it's not as though winning a
Democratic primary means you're the wave
of the future all across America it
means you want a Democratic Party in New
York for goodness sake yeah well Joe
Crowley didn't show up for the debate he
might be rethinking that at this point I
have about a minute left with you Ben
and I do want to ask you your reaction
to the huge news today the resignation
of Justice Kennedy and what you think I
mean it's just astonishing obviously I
was really not expecting that Justice
Kennedy would step down given that he's
the swing vote and it gives President
Trump an enormous opportunity to remake
the court in a conservative
constitutionalist image for a full
generation which is again present
President Trump has been both lucky and
good and he has an opportunity now that
he's been lucky to be good again here
yeah well I know you well maybe you
didn't suggest yourself but you did
suggest why not right
I knew the confirmation hearings would
be lit exactly they would be I think it
was Anne Coulter who first suggested
back when you were 21 when you were law
student at Harvard that you would
actually make an excellent Supreme Court
justice and as you pointed out today
you'd have a pretty good long run at it
most likely yeah exactly maybe they're
for a solid 60 years so mr. president if
you're looking for somebody who is gonna
have several decades on the court longer
than anybody else you're looking at I'll
throw my hat in the ring if not I'll
just cry myself might whitter feet is
just flowing right now with people who
are just jumping on board thank you so
much Pat it's always great to see you
thanks so much good to see you